All of us are fascinated by muscles and strength - whether we want to be stronger,
To feel better, or to look like a superman, there are many proposed strategies and systems
Aerobic exercise to reach this result. But what if I told you that this was out of your control, and that
Could it be your genetics that hinders you? Conversely, what if there is a secret
Can he connect you to superhuman power?
The truth is: the size of your muscles is a certain limit. Sure, this may seem obvious when you hear it,
But your muscles are under strict control of a protein called "myostatin", which determines
Exactly how much size will reach the muscle. This difference varies between people according to
Levels of metastatin. Once the muscle reaches this limit, the myostatin prevents any further growth.
But if the meostatin itself is limited or not, the muscle will suddenly grow beyond normal limits.
This phenomenon was first observed in the "Belgian blue cattle".
These cows developed a larger muscle mass 2-3 times than normal cows, and were discovered
Later she was suffering from deletion of the GDF-8 gene, which showed that it produced the myostatin.
As a result, without any exercise or diet, you own these cows
Amazing muscle mass. Similar cases are documented when dogs, mice and even
Some cases of human children lack the GDF-8 gene.
These results have helped scientists understand why muscle mass is easily increased, while others are struggling.
Low levels of myostatin equate to a larger muscle mass. In fact, some studies have shown
Many bodybuilders have naturally lower levels, or even a complete absence
For the histotin gene. If you look at someone like Arnold Schwarzenegger, for being a teenager,
It seems to grow muscle naturally. As such, many bodybuilders may owe their success
To inherit more than their training or use of real estate.
In the end, it may be possible to develop drugs that undermine or restrict the meostatin.
Of course, this is a double-edged sword; on the one hand, patients with muscular atrophy,
Or loss of muscle mass due to aging, restore the growth and safety of their muscles. On the other hand, it seems
The likelihood of misuse as a performance optimizer is unavoidable. But the possibility of seeing a real big man
Sounds fun. In addition, should we consider those who already have low levels of myostatin?
That they have an unfair advantage? It's hard to answer
Be wary of anyone selling or promoting this non-fixated and unregulated treatment.
At the end of the day, whether your meostatine levels are low or naturally elevated, remember
This level is optimal for your mechanical and metabolic function. With appropriate exercise
And public health, will reach the peak of your unique physiological functions. And though you are
You may not be ready to repel a punch like Superman, but you can reach your maximum limits through training
And work hard. But, what if you can hit the punches with Superman?
Our friend Jake has his program .. answer this huge supernatural question, which
You definitely need to watch it. And if you want to know how much of the ...
There is only one real way to do that. Start working.
This episode of AsapSEINCE is supported by "Me 23 and" a DNA analysis service
Which enables you to discover your genes, if you are interested in discovering your origins
Understanding your health and your susceptibility to the disease
Scan 23andme.com/asap. With the help of their DNA tools, continue with your past
Learn about your current health, and may be part of future genetic research
All at 23andme.com/asap Subscribe to more weekly science videos